[موسيقى]
مرحبا بكم اعزائي المشاهدين هي اكثر من
100 ساعه يتلاشى معها الامل شيئا فشيئا
بالوصول الى ناجين خاصه في ظل البرد
القارس الشديد عدد القتلى ارتفع الى نحو
25 الف شخص في كل من تركيا وسوريا في
تركيا وبحسب وزير الصحه التركيه تجاوز عدد
القتلى 20 الفا واكثر من ثمانين الف مصاب
اما في سوريا فاعلن المرصد السوري ان
حصيله القتلى جراء الزلزال وصلت الى اربعه
الاف وخمسمائه وهي مرشحه للوصول الى سته
الاف قتيل وفي مناطق اعلنت اليوم منكوبه
وهي حلب اللاذقيه حماه وادلب حجم الكارثه
في هذه المناطق يفوق قدره الجميع بحسب
منظمه الصحه العالميه
[موسيقى]
ووسط هذا الكم من الركام مكث تحت الانقاض
اكثر من اربعه ايام ونصف لكنه خرج على قيد
الحياه بعدما تم انقاذه اليكم مشاهدينا
هذه الصور المؤثره للحظه اخراج طفل وهو حي
يرزق في جبله بمحافظه اللاذقيه في سوريا
[موسيقى]
يلا يلا
طالعين
[موسيقى]
يا روحي
عبودي يا الله
وتمكنت فرقه الدفاع المدني في جبله ايضا
في اللاذقيه من انقاذ ام واولادها الثلاثه
من تحت مبنى المنهار نشاهد
[تصفيق]
الاشخاص وهو على قيد الحياه الف الحمد لله
الف الحمد لله
[تصفيق]
شو اسمه شو اسمه
شو اسمه يا شباب شو اسمه شو اسمه
شو اسمه الف الحمد لله على السلامه
ابراهيم زكريا وبعد 180 ساعات تحت الانقاض
تمكن رجال الانقاذ الاتراك من انقاذ رجل
في ولايه
[موسيقى]
وفي محاولات اطقم لانقاذ البحث عن ناجحه
تحت الانقاض برزت عده طرق
يستخدمونها اكثر من غيرها نتعرف عليها مع
مراسلنا زيدان زنكلو من اضنه جنوب تركيا
في المواقع المدمره نتيجه الزلزال الذي
ضرب تركيا تعتمد فرق الانقاذ على عده طرق
للتاكد مما اذا كان هناك ناجين تحت
الانقاض ام لا اولا الطريقه التقليديه
التي يقوم من خلالها احد رجال الانقاذ
باصدار نداءات متكرره بعد فتح فجوه بين
الركام وينتظر حتى يسمع ردا من الداخل في
حال لم يصله رد تلجا الفرق الى الطريقه
الثانيه وهي الكلاب المدربه التي تستشعر
وجود احياء كذلك تلجا فرق الانقاذ الى
استخدام كاميرات المراقبه الحراريه التي
تستطيع تحديد اماكن العالقين تحت الانقاض
طبعا نحن نصور هذا التقرير بعد انتهاء
التطبيق هذه الطرق لان الصمت والهدوء
التام شرط الاساسي لنجاح هذه الطرق زيدان
زنجلو اضنه
ويبقى معنا زيدان مباشره من اضنه زيدان
اهلا بك معنا بعد مشاهده هذا التقرير هل
ما زالت هناك اصوات تسمع من تحت الانقاض
ونحن في اليوم الخامس بعد الزلزال اكثر من
180 ساعات مرت منذ زلزال
مع الاسف صهيب لا اصوات من تحت الانقراض
حتى هذه اللحظه على الاقل في الموقع الذي
اتواجد فيه الان حتى حتى نبقى متفائلين
ربما يكون هناك اصوات ان شاء الله في
مواقع وولايات اخرى لكن من هذا الموقع
الذي نتواجد فيه هنا في مدينه اضنه حتى
الان لا اصوات مع الاسف تم اخراج جثه في
الساعه الماضيه من تحت ركام هذا المبنى
هناك ايضا جثه تحاول فرق الانقاذ ايضا
اخراجها من تحت الانقاض اليوم الخامس
تقريبا يوشك على النهايه ونقترب وتفصلنا
ساعات فقط من الدخول الى اليوم السادس
والامل والفرص فرص النجاد تتضائل لكن
حتى الان يعني الاخبار التي تاتي احيانا
من غازي عنتاب او عفوا من هاتاي او كهرمان
مرعش التي تحمل معها انقاذ او خروج بعض
الاشخاص ما زالوا على قيد الحياه تبعث
الامل في الامل رغم مرور هذه المده يبقى
هناك امل زيدان طيب حدثني عن فرق الانقاذ
وعن التكنولوجيات المستخدمه هنا في عمليات
البحث هكذا حالات كان هناك حديث على يعني
فرق انقاذ من 60 دوله قدمت الى تركيا
للمساعده في انقاذ الضحايا او اخراج
الناجين بالاساس يعني من تحت هذه الانقاض
في الولايات العشر التركيه المتضرره من
الزلزال هل من معطيات اكثر حول يعني حجم
المساعده الذي الذي تقدمه هذه الفرق
الاجنبيه من كل هذه الدول
نعم صهيب لا شك ان هناك مساعدات كثيره فرق
انقاذ وصلت بشكل كبير من عده دول في
محاوله
لمساعده فرق الانقاذ المحليه لديهم ايضا
اجهزه متطوره اضافه الى ان الفرق المحليه
وهنا الحقيقه ايضا لديها اجهزه متطوره
تساعد في رفع الانقاذ والكشف عن ناجين
لذلك فرق الانقاذ تاتي بدايه الى اضنه ومن
اضنه التي نتواجد فيها الان يتم توزيعها
على عده نقاط وتحديدا في الولايات في
الولايات الاكثر ضررا صهيب نتحدث تحديدا
عن هاتاي مرعش ايضا هنا في اضنه هناك
طواقم اجنبيه شاهدناها هناك طواقب من
تايلاند من الصين من اذربيجان ومن بلغاريا
ومن ايران هذه الطواقم شهدناها هنا في بعض
المواقع في هذا الموقع او في مواقع اخرى
زرناها خلال الايام الماضيه لا شك هي
اضافه يعني اضافه كبيره لكن نظرا لحجم
الدمار صهيب الدمار كبير نحن لا نتحدث عن
اضنه اضنه هي من اقل الولايات تضررا اضافه
الى ديار بكر وشارلي اورفا وعثمانيه وكلس
لكن في ولايات مثل
كهرمان مرعش وايضا ادمن وغازي عنتاب ريف
غازي عنتاب او الضواحي
الحجم الدمار هناك كبير جدا اكبر بكثير
فرق كل فرق الانقاذ التي اتت حتى الان
يعني بعض فرق الانقاذ سواء كانت المحليه
او الاجنبيه وصلت بعد يومين او ثلاثه ايام
الى بعض المواقع هناك تحدثنا على انه يعني
رغم تضاؤل الامال بعد مرور كل هذا الوقت
حوالي 180 ساعات ما يزال هناك بعض الامل
حدثني عن الناجين كيف يتم التكفل بهم طبعا
او المصابين كذلك في المستشفيات كيف هو
وضع المستشفيات ومن كتب له عمر العديد من
هذا الزلزال كيف يتم التكفل بهم حاليا من
قبل السلطات التركيه ما الذي وفرته حتى
الان
نعم بدايه قبل ان اجيب بشكل مباشر على هذا
السؤال قبل قليل صورت مقابله مع شخص يقيم
في جوار في بناء مجاور لهذا المبنى
المنهار وهو الان طبعا في مركز ايواء
حدثني ان
شقيقه اخيه او شقيقه وشقيقته وخالته
جميعهم كانوا في هذا المبنى المنهار تحت
في هذه اكوام الرماد التي شاهدناها وتم
اخراجهم جميع مع عائلاتهم بسلام خارج
او الى خارج هذا المبنى وتم اسعافهم
ونقلهم الى المشافي وهم الان في حاله جيده
لكن مع ذلك هو ما زال منذ خمسه ايام وحتى
اليوم يعني يتابع ويراقب وينتظر اخبار عن
جيرانه عن اصدقائه الذين كانوا هنا كان
يتحدث لي يعني صورت مقابله معه لقناه
العربيه سنرسلها بعد قليل وان شاء الله
تعرض قريبا قال لي يعني لا استطيع رغم ان
سعادتي بخروج اخي وشقيقتي وخالتي احياء
لكن انا حزين جدا يعني لا استطيع ان افرح
بقدر ما احزن عندما ارى
الاجساد تخرج من تحت الانقاض جميعهم او
قسم كبير منهم اعرفهم بشكل جيد اصدقاء
وجيران واشخاص كان لنا حياه مشتركه كان
هناك اطفال لهم امال ومستقبل يحلمون به
لكن مع الاسف كل هذا ذهب هباء منثوره يعني
حتى الناجين حتى اقرباء نجي نعم هناك فرحه
كبيره بخروج ذويهم واقربائهم
ولكن مشاعر الحزن هذه يعني امتدت للعالم
العربي يعني المشاهدون يعني هم يعني ونحن
نتابع ايضا من بعيد ما يحدث نشعر بهذا
الاسى فما بالك بمن له جار يعني فقده رغم
فرحته بالنجاه اسرته طيب زيدان لم تذكر لي
شيئا عن المستشفيات في عجاله لو سمحت
نعم نعم نعم لا شك هنا في بدايه اضنه في
في مدينه اضنه تم نقل الجرحى بدايه
الاشخاص الذين يتم اخراجهم على قيد الحياه
هنا في هناك فريق تدخل عاجل في حال كان
يحتاج الى علاج في الموقع قبل ان يغادر
سياره الاسعاف يتم نقلهم يتم علاجهم وتدخل
مباشره ثم نقلهم بسياره اسعاف الى المدينه
الطبيه هنا في اضنه في كحال شكرا
الى انقره او اسطنبول زيدان مباشره من
اضنه شكرا جزيلا لك
[موسيقى]
هذا واكدت فرق الطوارئ في سوريا ان
العديده من المنازل في حلب التي تلقت
الضربه الاكثر الى من الزلزال تضررت بشكل
كبير او انهارت تماما وبحسب الفرق لا يزال
الكثير من السكان عالقين تحت انقاض
البنايات في حلب التي يقيم فيها ملايين
اللاجئين الذين تشردوا بعدما افقدتهم
الحرب الاهليه منازلهم
[موسيقى]
متابع المشهد اذا في سوريا وبالتحديد من
القامشلي مع مراسلنا جمعه عكاش جمعه اهلنا
بك انت في القامش لاذان على الحدود
السوريه التركيه الخاضعه لسيطره الاداره
الذاتيه هل نقلت لنا المشهد من عندك وماذا
يحدث
مرحبا صهيب يعني كل الانظار تتجه الى
العثور على حياه جديده بين الانقاض وان
كانت الفرص اصبحت معدومه بشهاده فرق
الدفاع العامله في جميع المناطق يعني مره
حوالي 36 ساعه حتى الان لم تعثر فرق البحث
والانقاذ في كل المواقع المنكوبه على اي
نادي جديد
هي تنتشر فقط الجثث خلال ساعات 36 الماضيه
والفرص بالعثور عليهم تضاءلت الاوضاع تتجه
والجهود تتركز بشكل كبير في بلده جنديرس
التي يعمل فيها الدفاع المدني مع فريق
صغير من مصر وايضا من من اسبانيا على
انقاذ عن المنازل المتبقيه فرق الانقاذ
وصلت الى نصف المباني فقط في جنديرس نحن
نتحدث عن 84 مبنى 42 مبنى شملتها اعمال
البحث اما في اللاذقيه المنطقه الاكثر
الواقعه من المناطق الواقعه تحت سيطره
النظام لا تزال 70% من المباني في هذه
المدينه لم تصلها فرق البحث رغم ان هناك
فريق صيني واخر جزائري والقوات من لبنان
وايضا القوات قوات روسيه تشارك تشارك
الفرق المحليه فرق الدفاع ووزاره الدفاع
وايضا يعني بدايه الصحه لرفع الانقاذ عن
هذه المنازل بسبب الاعداد الكبيره من
المنازل المدمره التي لم يتم البحث فيها
يتوقع ان يرتفع عدد عدد القتلى بحدود
الالف وفقا يعني توقعات ادارات الفرق
والجهات المسؤوله التي نتواصل معها على
الدوام في ولا النهار
فيما يتعلق اذا بالمناطق السوريه ان
تحدثني اذا عن المناطق القاضيه على سيطره
النظام وايضا المعارضه جمعه
هل هناك
مساعدات ما المعلومات المتوفره عن
المساعدات او عن
الجهود كذلك اذا كان هناك اي مساعدات تدخل
من الجانب التركي بالنسبه للمناطق السوريه
خاصه المناطق الخاطئه المعارضه جمعه
طيب نحن نتحدث عن ثلاثه معابر مفتوحه مع
الجاره تركيا معبر باب الهواء دخلت منه
اليوم 14 شاحنه محمله بالمواد الاغاثيه من
الامم المتحده بينما معبر باب السلامه
دخلت منه اثنى عشر شاحنه مقدمه من مؤسسه
البرزاني الخيريه من اقليم كردستان العراق
عفرين اضافه نعم اضافه الى سبع شاحنات
اخرى مقدمه من رجال اعمال وجمعيات تبرعت
وجمعت الاموال في المغتربات واشترت
البضاعه من السوق التركيه وارسلتها الى
الداخل السوري بينما في مناطق النظام حيث
المطارات المنافذ الجويه المطارات دمشق
وحلب ولادقيه استقبلت 44 طائره علامتها
مئات الاطنان من المساعدات التي توجهت الى
مدن اللاذقيه جبله طرطوس وحلب مركز
المدينه اي في المناطق الخاضعه للسيطره
النظام لم تدخل حتى الان مناطق المعارضه
اضافه صهيب اذا كان الوقت يسمح هناك قافله
من 32 شاحنه محمله بالوقود والمواد
الاغاثيه عالقه في معبر ام جلود بين
مدينتي جرابلس منبج مقدمه من الاداره
الذاتيه لا يسمح بها لا يسمح بدخولها
الطرف اخر اي طرف المعارضه بسبب ضغوط من
تركيا التي تمنع التعامل مع الاداره ذاتيه
التعامل المعارضه مع الاداره ذاتيه نعم
شكرا جزيلا لك يا جماعه مباشره من
القامشلي
اذا نتحدث عن 108 ساعات مرت بعد الزلزال
طول هذه المده تمكن رجال الانقاذ الاتراك
من انقاذ رجل في ولايه هاتاي بعد ان قضى
طول هذه الفتره تحت الانقاض نتابع
[موسيقى]
هذا هو توعد الرئيس التركي رجب طيب برضو
جنب اتخاذ اجراءات عقابيه قاسيه بحق ما
يهاجمون الاسواق والمحلات التجاريه
وينهبون السلعه والمواد منها
مباني مدمره محلات تساوت بالارض والاخرى
بقيت صامده عدا نوافذها المحطمه يتسابق من
بقي في هذه المدن المتضرره من الزلزال الى
اكوام من الصناديق البعض بحثا عن
الاحتياجات الاساسيه واخرون استغلوا الوضع
الصعب للسرقه والنهب هنا نرى من يخرج
راكضا من محل تجاري بيده اساسيات غذائيه
او استهلاكيه وبالمقابل مشهد لاخرين
يخرجون اما خليل وفاض او بغنائمه كبيره
مهما كانت اسباب ومبرراته اولئك الاشخاص
الذين وثقت سرقاتهم عبر مقاطع فيديو ملات
مواقع التواصل الا ان الرئيس التركي رجب
طيب اردوغان اكد انه لهم بالمرصاد مستنكرا
استغلال البعض للظروف الصعبه الحاليه
مع الاسف هناك بعض الناس الذين يهاجمون
الاسواق والمحلات التجاريه وينهبون السلع
والمواد الدوله اتخذت التدابير وخطوات
ضدها هؤلاء وستتم معاقبتهم باشد الطرق
الرئيس التركي اعلن قبل ايام حاله الطوارئ
في البلاد لمده ثلاثه اشهر حاله قال انها
ستساهم في مساعده المدن المنكوبه والحد من
اعمال النهب والسرقه
روان حمزه العربيه
وانا من اسطنبول دكتور معهد اسطنبول للفكر
دكتور بكير اهلا بك معنا طبعا في ظل هذه
الكارثه الكبرى طبعا تبرز بعض المظاهر
السلبيه طبعا يعني مهما كانت المبررات
يعني يبدو المشهد سيئا الحقيقه امام هذه
السرقه والنهب في ظل هذه الظروف
ما حجم الظاهره برايك والى ما نعزوها
للاسف الشديد طبيعي يعني هذه شملت اكثر من
عشر مدن وما زالت بين الحين والاخر
الارتجازات المحليه او تكون وهذه تزيد
خطوره الوضع
النعم هناك للاسف بعض الناس تحاول استغلال
هذه الشيء من هم من يسرق منهم من يعني
ينهب واخرون طبيعي يحاولون الاستفاده من
هذا الفراغ الموجود خاصه في هذه المنازل
المنكوبه
الحكومه اخذت بعض التدابير مع انها ناقصه
ولكن للاسف هذه سوف تحصل لا نستطيع ان
نفعل شيئا سوى ان ناخذ التدابير اللازمه
ربما فيما بعد هناك كاميرات هناك
عن هذا هذه الظاهره التي ظهرت الان هناك
كذلك دعوات من المنظمات غير حكوميه
الى عدم تسييس الزلزال خاصه فيما يتعلق
بموضوع المساعدات وموضوع التفريق بين
تركيا وسوريا ومناطق النظام ومناطق
المعارضه هل برايك هناك امل ان يكون
اهتمام او تغليب الانسان على السياسه في
هذه الكارثه
لا بد منها يعني انا بنظري
يعني ان كانت تركيا او الدول التي قدمت
وتقدمت
الدعم لسوريا ولتركيا لابد ان تاخذ بعين
الاعتبار بان الشعب السوري والشعب التركي
هم اشقاء للاسف الشديد حتى الغضب الطبيعي
جاءت للاثنين معا لم تاتي لتركيا او للشعب
التركي فقط او للشعب السوري وانما جاءت
للشعبين معا حتى الغضب الطبيعي اذا هناك
روابط تاريخيه لابد النظر بها وان ننسى
الخلافات التي بيننا ربما ربما يعني اذا
اردنا ان نقول شيئا ان نقولها فيما بعد
وليس في هذه الظروف الحاسمه وفي هذه
المحنه الكبيره التي جاءت والتي فعلا
كبيره جدا ومئات
انها مؤسفه جدا جدا حقا هي مؤسفه لانه
المصاب واحد كما ذكرت
ونتحدث
ولكن حتى لا نتهم بالمثاليه لان هذا كلام
مثالي هذا يعني تمنيات لكن الحقيقه ان
هناك سياسه تغلب للاسف على على هذا الوضع
الانساني صعب وهناك مشاكل سياسيه بين بين
انقره ودمشق وهناك اتهامات من قبل المناطق
التي تسيطر عليها المعارضه بان الامم
المتحده لا تولي اهتماما او لم ترسل ما
يكفي من فرق لانقاذ
المحاصرين تحت تحت البنايات المنهاره جره
الزلزال برايك هل يمكن فعلا ان يكون هناك
فرصه سانحه الان لاستغلال هذا الظرف
لتحسين الاجواء السياسيه ام لا
للاسف الشديد يعني كانت هذه يجب ان تكون
منذ اللحظات الاولى وليست الان لان بعد
يعني ان راحت الضحايا الكسر في طرفين في
تركيا وسوريا وما زالت الناس يعني
منتصره كانت الاهتمام البالغ من المنظمات
الدوليه ومن الشعب التركي ايضا
لسوريا وحتى داخل سوريا بين بعضهم البعض
ولكن للاسف الشديد لن يحصل ما كنا نتمناه
الى الان للاسف الشديد انا مازلت اتمنى ان
تكون ولكن اجدها بعيده للاسف الشديد
والدول والمنظمات
وحتى القيادات في الدول كانت عليها ان
تاخذ بان الاعتبار بان هذه فرصه اها لكي
تتكارب وجهات النظر بين بعضهم البعض وان
يحافظوا على شعوب المنطقه من القتل
والدمار ولكن للاسف نجد مئات الاف الضحايا
وتزداد يوميا
ومعظم المنظمات والدول والمسؤولين
المتفرجين على ما يحصل هذه الكارثه الكبرى
شكرا جزيلا لك من اسطنبول دكتور بكر تجنن
انت مدير معهد اسطنبول شكرا لك
وفي حديثه العربيه اكدت المتحدثه باسم
برنامج الاغذيه العالمي في الشرق الاوسط
الحاجه الماسه لفتح المعابر السوريه
لتسهيل ايصال المساعدات للمتضررين من
الزلزال
لمئه الف شخص وجبات
لا تحتاج الى طه تكفي لمده اسبوع وهناك
مخزون يكفي الى يكفي مليون ونصف
شخص ولكنها حصص غذائيه شهريه ولكن تحتاج
الى بالنسبه لدخول المساعدات نحن نستخدم
ممر باب الهوى نحن نستخدم المعابر في داخل
سوريا ولكن بسبب يعني بسبب الزلزال
والدمار الطرقات
مدمره ولذلك هناك بطء لذلك
ندعو الى فتح مزيد من الممرات هذا كان
هناك باب السلام يدخل منه تدخل منه
المساعدات فقط البطء البطء الوصول بسبب
الدمار في المنطقه
قالت منظمه الصحه العالميه ان الزلزال
اعاد الى الواجهه ما وصفته بالازمه
المنسيه في سوريا واكدت انها مستعده
لارسال مساعدات كبيره الى سوريا لكنها
تواجه الكثير من القيود الصحه العالميه
اضافت ان حجم الكارثه في سوريا كبير
للغايه ويفوق قدره الجميع واشارت الصحه
العالميه الى ان الزلزال الذي دمر ارجاء
كبيره من المدن في سوريا اعاد تسليط الضوء
على سوريا التي تعاني اصلا
هذا واقل المدير الاقليمي للجمعيات الصليب
الاحمر والهلال الاحمر لمنطقه الشرق
الاوسط وشمال افريقيا حسام شرقاوي في لقاء
مع العربيه ان الاوضاع في الشمال السوري
صعبه داعيا في الوقت ذاته الى تنحيه
السياسه جانبا والتركيز على ايصال
المساعدات لكل سوريا في مناطق فيها وضع
امني حساس في مناطق وصلتها المعونات وهذا
يدور 24 ساعه
الوضع ماساوي كما كل التقارير تفيد وبدات
تظهر حجم الدمار
بنحس الجميع انه نحط السياسه على جنب
ونركز على انقاذ الناس وتقديم المعونه
تواصلوا فرق الانقاذ الدوليه عملها في
المناطق المتضرره في تركيا وسوريا ومن
الفرق المستمره في العمل على الارض فريق
الانقاذ الاردني الذي يضم تسعه وتسعين
منقدا متخصصا واطباء من الخدمات الطبيه
الملكيه والذي انضم لفرق انقاذ من عده دول
حول العالم تعمل الان على الارض في سوريا
وتركيا
وفي ادلب ايضا التقطت كاميرا العربيه صورا
تظهر حجم الدمار في رفيق ادلب
[تصفيق]
شوي شوي
[موسيقى]
من انهيار الصحه العامه في شمال غرب سوريا
مع اتضاح اثار الزلزال المدمر وقالت
اللجنه في بيان ان الاضرار الكبيره التي
لحقت بالمرافق الصحيه التي تعاني بالفعل
من الضغوط الشديده والبنيه التحتيه
الحيويه مثل الطرق والجسور تعني ان النظام
الصحيه الذي تضرر بشده بالفعل بعد 12 عاما
من الصراع اصبح الان يترنح تحت ضغط الطلب
المتزايد على الخدمات
عمليه التي اصابت البلاد
من دمشق معنى عبر سكايب الكتب الصحفي عبد
الحميد توفيق استاذ عبد الحميد اهلا بك
معنا الى هذه التغطيه من العربيه الحكومه
السوريه في دمشق تعهدت بايصال المساعدات
التي تصلها كذلك الى المناطق الخاضعه
للسيطره المعارضه والخارجه عن سيطرتها كيف
ستقوم بذلك
مساء الخير استاذ صهيب مساء الخير الاستاذ
المشاهدين في الواقع الان ينجلي هذا اللقط
الذي انطلق منذ فجر الاثنين او بعد الظهر
الاثنين يوم الفاجعه الكبرى للشعبين
السوري والتركي على حد سواء بكيفيه ايصال
المساعدات وكذلك
الانقسام الجغرافي العمودي بين الدوله
السوريه وبين فصائل المعارضه التي تسيطر
على كثير من الاجزاء الشماليه التي تضررت
ايضا اليوم تنجلي هذه القصه والامر بسيط
ولا يحتاج الى كثير جهد وكنا نتحدث دائما
كنا نتحدث دائما بان هناك عاملان الاول ان
منظمه الامم المتحده بكل افرعها وهيئاتها
لم تغادر سوريا حتى في ايام الحرب التي
مرت عليها في عام 2011 وحتى الان وبالتالي
كان ببساطه يمكن التعاطي والتعامل
والتنسيق عن طريق الامم المتحده ومكاتبها
في سوريا من قبل الدول التي تريد ان تقدم
مساعداتها
تربطها علاقات دبلوماسيه على خلفيه
الاحداث التي حدثت كل الاتحاد الاوروبي
ودوله ومنظماته وكذلك الولايات المتحده
الامريكيه وغيرها المتضامنه معها وبالتالي
كان يمكن ان تكون منذ اليوم الاول كنا
نتحدث ولكن للاسف كان هناك تسييس في
البدايه العامل الثاني الذي يسهل هذه
الامور هو ان الطرق الرئيسيه الواصله من
دمشق الى حلب من دمشق الى اللاذقيه من
دمشق الى حمام دمشق الى ادلب وكذلك شبكه
الخطوط الداخليه البريه السوريه موجوده
وهي غير متضرره
نعم يعني نعي ذلك بالفعل ولكن عمليا
الطرفان يعني في حاله حرب يعني منذ سنوات
كيف هل يمكن يعني انه في ظل الزلزال يعني
او في ظل هذه الكارثه يعني يتم تناسي
احقاد الماضي وتقديم المساعدات هكذا عن
طيب خاطر
بدايه نتمنى كشعب سوري ان يتم نسيان هذه
الاحقاد وتجاوزها وطيها هذه الصفحه وفتح
صفحه جديده للتفاهم لان اليوم الجرح يجب
ان يوحد السوريين ونتمنى ان يوحدوا
السوريين هذا الجرح الكبير وهذه الغضب
الطبيعي الذي ادى الى هذه الكارثه
الانسانيه الكبرى في ظل ظروفا يعيشها
الشعب السوري على كل الصعد سواء في
الاراضي التي تخضع لسيطره الدوله السوريه
او تلك التي تخضع لسيطره المعارضه الجرح
واحد والالم واحد والنكبه كبرى لدى
الطرفين واستطيع القول بكل شفافيه ان
المساعدات التي وردت الى دمشق وحلب
واللاذقيه عبر المطارات من الدول العربيه
وغير العربيه الدول الصديقه للسوريه كانت
كبيره وهائله وبالتالي كان هناك الامكانات
المتواضعه الموجوده يمكن ان تعمل ولكن
المشكله موجوده ايضا في مناطق الشمال التي
تخضع لسيطره المعارضه تلك المناطق هي
بالاساس غير مؤهله ولا بنيه تحت قطاعاتها
ولا يوجد فيها امكانيات وقد تاخر عليها
تاخرت عليها الاغاثه لاسباب لا نريد ان
ندخل في تفاصيلها ولكن يبدو ان السياسه في
البدايه نعم السياسه في البدايه نعم على
ذكر التجاوز العقوبات على دمشق يعني من
قبل المجتمع الدولي كذلك من قبل الغرب
بالتحديد امام هذه الفاجعه هي فاجعه صحيح
ولكن هل تكون بالنسبه لدمشق رب ضاره نافعه
يعني هل بسبب هذه الازمه
ربما ستتحسن علاقات دمشق علاقات النظام مع
الدول التي توترت معها علاقاتها خلال
العشر سنوات الماضيه
هناك سياقان لهذا في هذا الجواب لسؤالك
استاذ صهيب الاول فيما يتعلق بالعامل
العربي والدول الصديقه التي لم تدخل في
عداوه مباشره ومعلنه مع الدوله السوريه
والحكومه السوريه اعتقد بانها فرصه جدا
مهمه واليوم كل تقريبا اكثر من 14 دوله
عربيه تصب باغاثاتها عبر المطارات وعبر
البر سواء البر العراقي البر اللبناني
والبر الاردني لو يرتبط بذلك ولكن على
الصعيد الاخر في المسار الاخر المسار
الاوروبي والمسار لان تديره الولايات
المتحده الامريكيه
وتنسقاني في هذا في هذه المواقف على مدار
السنين الماضيه وهناك القوانين العقوبات
التي استثنيت اعلن رسميا ان قانون قيصر
سيستثنى من هذه
180 يوما سته اشهر فيما يتعلق بامرين
ايصال بعض المواد الاغاثه
وبطريقتهم الخاصه كما الامريكيون او وزير
الخزانه الامريكيه تحديدا قبل ساعات قليله
وكذلك بمساله التحويلات الماليه
لمساعده الاهالي وايضا الايغاثه سواء كانت
منظمات او من اشخاص باتجاه الداخله السوري
لم الى الان لم يعلن اي طرف انه سيقوم
بالتنسيق في هذا الاطار مع الحكومه
السوريه مباشره او مع الحكومه السوريه
ولكن بطريقه غير مباشره عبر هياته ومنظمات
الامم المتحده في كل الاحوال
الزمن فات على مساله هؤلاء الضحايا بعد
مروركها هذه
الايام ولكن اليوم لابد ايضا من فعل ما
يجب فعله على امله من رحم ربنا ان يكون
هناك روح لا زالت تلهت بحياتها ووجودها
شكرا جزيلا لك عبد الحميد توفيق انتم
الكاتب الصحفي السوري كنت معنا مباشره من
دمشق
بعد ان تحولت اجزاء كبيره من شمال سوريا
بطرفه عين الى مناطق منكوبه بقيه
المساعدات الدوليه خجوله لا تليق بحجم
اكبر زلزال تم تسجيله على اليابسه يقتلون
المعهد الايطالي للجيو فيزياء خمسه ملايين
الف شخص اصبح مشردين بلا ماوى في سوريا
بسبب الزلزال رقم كبير قدرته مفوضيه
اللاجئين التابعه للامم المتحده المناطق
المنكوبه هنا في الشمال السوري دفعت لجنه
الايقاظ الدوليه الى تحذير من انهيار
الصحه العامه وسط تحذيرات من كارثه جديده
بعد الزلزال تتمثل بفقدان الارواح بسبب
نقص المعدات الطبيه اللازمه وفق منظمه
الصحه العالميه هذا الامر اشتكى منه
مستشفى ادلب واكد ان تقطف لا تستوعب العدد
الكبير من المصابين اضافه الى نقص حاد في
المواد الطبيه والاجهزه
المصابين بشكل عام ووضعهم سيء جدا بحاجه
الى رعايه طبيه فائقه بحاجه الى اجهزه
بحاجه لمستهلكات ادويه
لطاقتك كانت تكفي للتعامل مع هذا العدد
الكبير من الاصابات تحذير الامم الاخر
اطلقته يونس اعربت عن مخاوفها من ارتفاع
عدد مرضى الكوليرا في سوريا نتيجه تعرض
شبكه المياه الى الدمار بسبب الزلزال ورغم
هذا المشهد الماساوي تاخر وصول المساعدات
لتدخل اول قافله للامم المتحده بعد ايام
على الكارثه مؤلفه من عشرين شاحنه فقط ضمت
معدات انسانيه وخياما وبطانيات لكنها
خاليه من اي مواد غذائيه واخرى ضروريه
لعمليه البحث والانقاذ
فاطمه احمد هي سيده سوريه انجبت ابنها نجم
بعد الزلزال مباشره والتي ذكرت انها واجهت
لحظات صعبه بسبب خوفها على فقدان مولودها
الا انها نجت هي وابنها من الزلزال الذي
عاصفه بارواح الكثيرين
بس موقف صعب ماكل يعني
[موسيقى]
الله يحمي لي اياه ويخلي لي اياه طيب ولا
يحرمني منه لانه بالنسبه لي هو اللي رجعني
للحياه يعني انه خفت لدرجه
بلغت جهود انقاذ المفقودين في الزلزال
الذي ضرب اجزاء واسعه من تركيا وسوريا
يومها الخامس اذا وبينما يسابق المنقذون
الزمن من اجل العثور على احياء لا زالت
الجهود تثمر بحالات شكل صمودها مفاجاه
بسبب درجات الحراره المنخفضه التي تشهدها
المنطقه
اخيرا صيحه الالم احيت امال المنقذين في
بلده جنديرس السوريه دقائق معدوده واسيا
البالغه من العمر 10 سنوات تغادر الجحيم
بعد 90 ساعه قضتها تحت الرك
بدون اكل ولا شرب وفي درجات حراره متجمده
اليوم الخامس بعد الزلزال المعجزات ما
زالت تتحقق
في الليله نفسها حفر عمال الانقاذ لساعات
بايادي عاريه
هزه ارتداديه جديده كافيه لاعادتهم لنقطه
الصفر
تجلى الغبار واستقبلت الفتاه بالتصفيق
وجوه بريئه تحولت الى رمز للصمود اما
شجاعتهم فقد الهمت الموقلين
عائلات اخرى كانت اكثر حظا
انقذت البنت ساعتين من بعدها التحق الاب
رغم الصدمه يمسك بشده بيد موقده
كلمته الاولى ترجمه مشاعره
ناصر بقي يقظا لايام وكان شهيدا على اخراج
افراد عائلته الواحده والاخر
كتبت الحياه لثلاثه ابناء الا ان الام
غادرت مع البقيه خروجها من تحت الركام لم
يدم طويلا عاد ناصر برفقه فريق الانقاذ
لدفنها غير بعيد عما كان بيته
اطلعت قلت يا ربي بس سلم لي واحد بدي واحد
بس منها الاولاد من شفت طلعت وما ناديت
فيصل ناديت مشعل محسن منصور ما حدا رد
قلت ما وصلوا معناته ماتوا
صور حيه للمعجزات لكن كم من الاتراك
والسوريين لم يسعفوا الحظ
فرق الانقاذ في سباق مع الساعه مرور الوقت
يعني املا اقل اجواء متجمده وهزات
ارتداديه تعيق المهمه
اما من كتبت لهم الحياه فعليهم خوضوا
معركه صمود جديده
[موسيقى]
وصلت الى مطار غازي عنتاب في تركيا اليوم
طائرتا الاغاثه الرابعه والخامسه واتقلان
فريق البحث والانقاذ السعودي مع جميع
التجهيزات التي يحتاجها من الاليات
والمعدات والمضخات والادويه الطبيه
والتجهيزات الفنيه للمساهمه في جهود انقاذ
ضحايا الزلزال عدد محسن الحربي
في هذه الاثناء الى مطار غازي عنتاب
الفريق الفريق الانقاذ السعودي المكون من
مختصا في عمليات الانقاذ في مختلف
التخصصات بالاضافه الى تخصصات طبيه دقيقه
تتعامل مع حالات الاحتجاز هذا الفريق
الطبي
الفريق الانقاذ المكون من مختلف تخصصات
بالاضافه الى فريق طبي سيبدا في العمل في
غازي عنتاب وفي المناطق المتضرره الاخرى
مباشره
ومساعده كافه السلطات التي تعمل على سلطات
الانقاذ التي تعمل على رفع
الاجزاء من المنازل المهدمه والمتضرره
جراء الزلزال والتي ستباشر بالتنسيق مع
السلطات التركيه مع مختلف القطاعات
المختلفه العامره في هذه الازمه جراء
الزلزال عبد المحسن الحربي العربيه م
حضرت منظمه اليونيسف من مخاطر انتشار واسع
للامراض المنقوله بواسطه المياه عقب زلزال
المدمر في تركيا وسوريا في وقت يثير فيه
نقص الوقود والكهرباء والمياه النظيفه
مخاوف جمعيات الاغاثه الخيريه وفق موقع
اكسبرس البريطاني
من نجى من فتك الزلزال به وبمنزله قد لا
ينجو من كارثه صحيه تتربص به الكوليرا عدو
اخر يهدد سوريا وتركيا
ناقوس الخطر دقته منظمه اليونيسف التي
حذرت من مخاطر انتشار واسع للامراض
المنقوله بواسطه المياه حيث تبقى مخاطر
الاصابه بامراض مثل الكوليرا
والاسهالتاريا في اعلى مستوياتها على
الاطلاق في اعقاب كارثه الزلزال في سوريا
تم اعلان تفشي الكوليرا قبل خمسه اشهر في
اعقاب الزلزال ربما تكون مصادر المياه
النظيفه القليل المتاحه قد تضررت ايضا
قلق عالمي يتزايد اذا انتشار وباء
الكوليرا الذي ظهر مجددا في سوريا
والارقام تحكي عن رصد 84 الف حاله كوليرا
منذ سبتمبر الماضي حتى بدايه هذا العام
المعطيات وفق المنظمات الصحيه تشير الى
ازدياد الحالات ان لم تتم معالجه الشبكات
المتضرره بالسرعه الممكنه
الحال نفسها في تركيا وان كانت بدرجات اقل
المياه غمرت شوارع بعض المناطق المتضرره
من الزلزال
وسط تقارير غربيه تشير الى نقص حاد في
المياه الصالحه للشرب في تلك المناطق
الامر الذي يضاعف الخسائر وينذر بكارثه
صحيه اخرى قبل الاستفاقه من صدمه الكارثه
الزلزال
ورغم تضاؤل حظوظ اخراج ناجنه من تحت
الانقاض بمرور خمسه ايام على الزلزال
المدمر لم يفقد الشاب السوري سامر المتطوع
في فرق الانقاذ العام الامل لم يفقد الامل
في العثور على صديقه المفقود تحت انقاضي
بلده جنديرس شمالي سوريا ما حدا بيعرف
فينا شيء خالص خالص هنا بجنديرس شمالي
سوريا حيث النصيب الاكبر من الكارثه
المتطوعون من اهالي البلده كان وحدهم من
جابها هولا الزلزال اليومين قبل انضمام
فرق الانقاذ قليله العدد شحيحه المعدات
طعن عالم عايشين طارنا عالم ميتين بايدينا
بحثنا بايدينا كريكات
بالعصي بالبواري ايش نلاقي قدامنا نعزل
طالعنا عايشين طلعنا ميتين
ضلينا لثاني يوم لحتى هون
اجا الدفاع المدني اجوا اجوا العالم
تساعدنا في جنديرس قصه البحث عن الناجين
تاخذ معنى اخر
سامر الذي انقذ العشرات منذ اربعه ايام
انهكه التعب لكن انامله لم تتوقف عن البحث
فشخص عزيز عليه تحت هذا الركام رفيق دربه
وابن حارته المدمره ما يزال في عداد
المفقودين اول بنايه وصل عليها هو البنايه
اللي ساكن فيها رفيقي رفيقي اسمه علي هو
ما وصلت
لا كان في لا دفاع مدني لا كان في شيء
يعني انا لحد الان هذا ثالث يوم رابع يوم
انا هون يعني اهلي ما بعرف عنه غير انه
اوصل بس اشوفه انه عايشين وارجع فقط لا
غير
ضلينا نبحث لحد الان
[تصفيق]
ديرس لا يحتاجون الى قوائم المفقودين فهم
يعرفون من قضى نحبه ومن ينتظر وهذا الجهد
المتواصل بالنسبه اليهم هو الواجب اتجاه
الاهل والوفاء قبل التضامن علمنا اعز
رفقاتي ابو قلب الطيب الحنون
يعني ما فينا نقول شيء غير حسبنا الله
ونعم الوكيل
عبد القادر خربوش العربيه
جهات عديده انتفضت لتقديم المساعده لضحايا
الزلزال الذي ضرب تركيا وسوريا عالم كره
القدم لم يكن بعيدا عن ذلك
عالم كره القدم يهب لمساعده ضحايا الزلزال
[موسيقى]
مع ان يمكننا تحقيق اي شيء في الاوقات
الصعبه
العديد من لاعبي كره القدم انضموا لحمله
بيع قمصان اللاعبين للتبرع بعوائدها
للمنكوبين
خلال الساعات القليله الماضيه بيعه قمصان
لاعبين عالميين مقابل مبالغ كبيره من
بينهم البرتغالي كريستيانو رونالدو
الارجنتيني
والايطالي ليوناردو بونوتشي
تبرعات ماديه ضخمه قدمها ليونيل ميسي تقدر
بثلاثه ملايين ونصف المليون يورو
فرق كره القدم التركيه هبت بدورها لتقديم
المساعده ابرزها فريق غالاتا سراي ونادي
بيشكتاش
خلال زلزال عام 1906 تزحزحت منطقه الزلزال
نحو سته امتار وفي تركيا نفسها تزحزح صدع
الاناضول خلال زلزال ازميت عام 199 باكثر
من مترين ونصف واليوم اشار علماء جيولوجيا
الى ان جانبا من صفيحه الاناضول تحرك
لحوالي ثلاثه امتار لكن كيف تتحرك الصفائح
التكتونيه الاجابه في التقرير التالي
زلزال في السادس من فبراير كان ضخما جدا
وفي المناطق المنكوبه من الصعب على
الناجين فهما حجم ما حدث وهذا ما تحدثوا
عنه لكن لفهم ما جرى بالضبط سنتخيل ان سطح
الارض هو عباره عن احجيه عن بازل الطبقه
الخارجيه منها ليست متصله هي مكونه من
صفائح ضخمه تقريبا عشرون عشرين قطعه
متداخله مع بعضها البعض وبنفس الشكل الذي
تتخذه الاحجيات لكنها تستمر في الحركه
وببطء وبمعدل سنتيمتر الى 20 في السنه اما
ان تتباعد او تصطدم ببعضها او تنزلق عبر
حدودها
ما احدث الزلزال الاول وما تلاه منطقيا
كان تحركا عنيفا تمزق على اثره امتداد
الصدع بين صفيحتي الاناضول والعربيه التي
تقع تركيا على خطوطه مع الصفيحه الوراثيه
ايضا تركيا تحركت مشاهدينا بثلاثه امتار
خلال ثواني نعم الجغرافيا تغيرت البلد
باكمله تحرك نحو الغرب
غير او تغير مكانه
[موسيقى]
سنواصل معكم تغطيه للزلزال لكن نتوقف الان
امام بعض الاخبار الخاصه بملفات اخرى
ونبدا من اسرائيل حيث وجه رئيس الوزراء
الاسرائيلي بتعزيز قوات الامن في منطقه
القدس على خلفيه وقوع هجوم بالدهس اليوم
والذي اسفر عن سقوط قتيلين واصابه سبعه
مستوطنين في ريموت بعضهم داخل المراحل
الخضراء كما وجه نتنياهو ايضا بالتحرك
الفوري لاغلاق منزل منفذ العمليه وهدمه
بالاضافه الى القاء القبض على الاشخاص ذي
الصله بالمهاجم
اصدرت وزاره الاستخبارات والحرس الثوري
الايراني بيانا يفيد باعتقال السلطات
المنفذي لهجوم اصفهان بالطائرات المسيره
وذلك وفقا لوكاله انباء تسنيم الايرانيه
والتي افادت ايضا بان السلطات تعرفت على
اشخاص قالت انهم تابعون لاسرائيل في
الهجوم بالطائرات المسيره على احد المراكز
الصناعيه الخاصه بالصواريخ في اصفهان
شهدت مدينه زهدان عاصمه بلوشستان في ايران
احتجاجات كبيره اليوم عقب صلاه الجمعه
المتظاهرون طالبوا باطلاق سراح السجناء
السياسيين في ايران واسقاط النظام
الايراني وقال امام اهل السنه في ايران
مولوي عبد الحميد ان كافه الشعب الايراني
يريد التمتع بحقوق متساويه دون تمييز لاحد
مؤكدا على ان الشعب الايراني انتفض
لادراكه ان المشكله لا يمكن حلها
شددت الخارجيه الروسيه على ان نشره صواريخ
الامريكيه التي تفوق سرعتها سرعه الصوت في
اليابان يؤثر على الامن والاستقرار
الاستراتيجي في العالم اقلت الناطقه باسم
الخارجيه الروسيه ماريا زخارفا ان روسيا
ستراقب عن كثب اي استعدادات لتنفيذ خطه
واشنطن مؤكده ان تنفيذها سيعني تغييرا في
الامن الاقليمي وكانت تقارير اعلاميه
افادتنا واشنطن اقترحت نشره صواريخ متوسطه
المدى في اليابان كجزء من خطه لتعزيز
الدفاعات ضد الصين على طول بحر الصين
الشرقي والجنوبي
قال الرئيس الامريكي جو بايدن ان المنطقه
الصيني الذي دخل المجال الجوي لبلاده لم
يشكل انتهاكا خطيرا للامن القومي للولايات
المتحده ولكنه يعتبر انتهاكا للقوانين
الدوليه كما اشار الرئيس الامريكي ان جيش
بلاده اتخذ قرارا حكيما عندما قرر اسقاط
المنطاد قباله سواحل كارولينا الجنوبيه
قام مكتب التحقيقات الفيدراليه بتفتيش
منزل نائب الرئيس الامريكي السابق مايك
بانس في اطار قضيه ارشيد البيت الابيض
وفقه وسائل الاعلام من محليه وعلى غرار جو
بايدن تم العثور على وثائق سريه في منزل
بولايه انديانا في نهايه شهر يناير الماضي
واجر التفتيش الجديد بالتنسيق بين مكتب
التحقيقات الفيدرالي ومحامي بانس بحسب
صحيفه واشنطن
افادت انباءنا ان بطله تسلق الجليد والعضو
السابقه في المنتخب الايراني زينب كبرى
موسوي قررت اللجوء من ايران وذهب للعيش في
سويسرا هذا ويذكر ان موسوي انسحبت من
المنتخب الايراني في عام 2019 وذلك
احتجاجا على موقف اتحاد تسلق الجليد
الايراني منها وعدم ارسالها الى المسابقات
الدوليه
مشاهدينا التغطيه المستمره عبر العربيه
لكارثه الزلزال الذي ضرب تركيا وسوريا بعد
قليل تلقاكم الزميله رشا نبيل في تغطيتنا
المستمره